5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE SENATE SCRAMBLING AS THE
CLOCK TICKS TO AVOID A PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AT MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT.
A LIVE LOOK AT THE SENATE FLOOR
WHERE REPUBLICANS ARE ATTEMPTING
TO MOVE FORWARD ON A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHERE THEY HAVE THE
NUMBERS GOING FORWARD.
OVER AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
PRESIDENT TRYING TO PLACE THE
POTENTIAL BLAME AT DEMOCRATS'
FEET.
>> IT'S REALLY UP TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
TOTALLY UP TO THE DEMOCRATS
WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE A
SHUTDOWN.
I HOPE WE NOT, BUT WE ARE
TOTALLY PREPARED FOR A VERY LONG
SHUTDOWN.
THIS IS OUR ONLY CHANCE THAT
WE'LL HAVE OR HAVE IN OUR
OPINION BECAUSE OF THE WORLD AND
THE WAY IT BREAKS DOWN.
TO GET GREAT BORDER SECURITY.
>> SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING THAT TRUMP
WOULD BE AT FAULT AND DEMOCRATS
WILL NOT BE BUDGING ON ANY EXTRA
FUNDING FOR THE BORDER WALL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP?
YOU WILL NOT GET YOUR WALL.
ABANDON YOUR SHUTDOWN STRATEGY.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE WALL
TODAY.
NEXT WEEK.
OR ON JANUARY 3RD WHEN DEMOCRATS
TAKE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
>> JESSE, EVERYONE IS FIGURING
OUT, WHAT'S THE END GAME HERE?
HOW DOES THE PRESIDENT PLAY OUT
THE STRATEGY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I DON'T SEE THE END GAME
HERE, JUAN.
IF HE HAS A BILL THAT GETS TO
HIS DESK AND IT DOESN'T HAVE
WALL FUNDING, HE VETOES IT.
HE SIGNS IT AND SAYS I TRIED.
IF HE VETOES IT, GOES BACK,
EVERYTHING GETS SHUT DOWN.
MAYBE IT'S A SHUTDOWN FOR A WEEK
AT MOST AND THE DEMOCRATS COME
IN AND TAKE OVER AND THEY NEVER
SEND HIM ANYTHING WITH ANY WALL
FUNDING AND YOU ARE BACK WITH
SQUARE ONE.
I DO NOT SEE THE END GAME.
I THINK HE'S TRYING TO SIGNAL TO
THE PEOPLE THAT HE'S GOING TO
FIGHT, BUT HE HAS TO FIND
CREATIVE WAYS IN THE BUDGET TO
BUILD THIS WALL.
THE WALL HAS TO BE BUILT.
THAT'S HIS SIGNATURE PROMISE.
HE WASTED THE FIRST TIME WITH
IT.
McCONNELL DIDN'T DELIVER THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S A SHAME.
IF THEY GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER, WHICH THEY WANT, YOU
COULD GET A WALL.
THE OTHER SIDE WITH GET STUFF,
THIS SIDE WOULD GET STUFF.
BUT THE WAY THE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED IN THE SENATE?
60 VOTES FOR THESE SPENDING
BILLS?
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET WHAT
YOU WANT.
YOU ARE GOING TO USE THEIR
SHUTDOWN AS LEVERAGE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT HOW BORING
IT IS.
>> DANA, LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT
HOW IT'S BORING.
IT'S A HOT ISSUE IN PUBLIC
OPINION.
QUINNIPIAC HAS A POLL OUTCOME UP
IF THE 4%, NO NEED TO A WALL 64%
AVOID A SHUTDOWN.
54% SAY YES TO THE WALL AMONG
REPUBLICANS.
>> I WOULD IMAGINE THAT 60% OF
DEMOCRATS SAY --
>> IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
>> IT'S THE SAME.
IT'S QUITE PARTISAN.
I THOUGHT THE LANGUAGE THAT TED
CRUZ USED EARLIER TODAY WAS
INTERESTING BUT I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR MORE OF IT COMING FROM
REPUBLICANS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE EXTREME AND THEY ARE
PARTISAN, THE PRESIDENT IS THE
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THE
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THR
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THA
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THD
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THO
ONE WHO     WHO IS MIDDLE-OF-THN
THIS AND COMMONSENSICAL.
SOME OF THEM POINTING BACK TO
FEBRUARY WHEN THE PRESIDENT HAD
THE CAMERAS IN AND THAT WAS IN
THE CABINET ROOM AND IT WAS THE
MOST AMAZING MEETING ANYBODY
SEES?
THAT DEAL WITH THE GIVEN
$25 BILLION PLUS THE D ACA FIX.
YOU GO BACK, GOSH, MAYBE THAT'S
THE DEAL THEY SHOULD'VE HAD BACK
THEN.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE SO DUG IN
SAYING NO THAT BRIAN SCHATZ, THE
SENATE OR FROM HAWAII, WENT BAC.
HE FLEW BACK, SAID NO.
THAT'S COMMITMENT.
>> THAT IS MY DECISION!
THAT'S THE NAME OF MY NEW SHOW
ON FOX NATION, THINGS HAPPEN.
>> IT'S MAKING A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVE RADIO, THE" ORS,
RUSH LIMBAUGHS, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING!
YOU CAN ALLOW THE DEMOCRATS TO
WIN.
WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DO?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> HE'S WATCHING.
>> WHEN I LISTEN TO THIS, I
REMINDED TO BE VERY FOOLISH.
IT REMINDS ME OF ABOUT THE YANNI
OR LAUREL THING.
TRUMP HAS MANAGED TO GET
DEMOCRATS TO AGREE HAVING A
STRONG BOARD IS IMPORTANT.
WHENEVER THEY GET IN THE
-- EVERYBODY IS SAYING, HERE
GOES, OKAY, AND WALL.
THEY GO, NO, NOT A WALL.
THEY ACTUALLY -- THE BOTH SIDES
AGREE, BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
HUNG UP ON LANGUAGE.
THEY ARE HUNG UP ON LANGUAGE.
IT'S THE WORD.
IT'S THE WORD WALL.
MIGHT I QUOTE SOMEBODY?
>> SCOTT?
>> YES, SCOTT ADAMS.
WHY NOT ADJUST THE LANGUAGE.
IF IT'S A WALL, FENCE, WHO
CARES?
CALL IT A WENCE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS PEOPLE
TO CALL IT STEEL SLATS?
>> STEEL SLAT SOUNDS FANTASTIC
TO ME.
THAT SOUNDS PRETTY COOL.
YOU CAN MOVE IT AROUND.
DEMOCRATS WILL SAY THAT THIS IS
THE WRONG WAY TO CUT
IMMIGRATION.
MOST OF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
IS OVERSTAYED VISAS BEAR THAT'S
LIKE SAYING, I DON'T LIKE A FORT
BECAUSE IT WON'T CUT MY MEET
YOU CAN HAVE A WALL, STRONG
BORDER.
YOU CAN AGGRESS THAT OTHER
STUFF.
THE ARGUMENTS ARE EITHER
EMOTIONAL, FLAWED, PIGHEADED.
EVERYBODY WANTS THE SAME THING,
BUT THEY WON'T GIVE IN.
>> JEDEDIAH, IF WE DO HAVE A
SHUTDOWN AT NIGHT, THEY'LL SEE
800,000 FEDERAL WORKERS, 47% OF
THAT WILL NOT COME TO WORK.
THE REST COME TO WORK, THEY
WON'T BE PAID UNTIL THE
GOVERNMENT REOPENS.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE THE BACKPAY.
>> FEDERAL CONTRACTORS OUT OF
WORK TOO.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THEY'LL KEEP DOING VISAS,
RESTROOMS, SOME OF THE FEDERAL
PARKS WILL BE CLOSED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL BE THE
REACTION?
>> FROM THE RIGHT, PEOPLE GOT
VERY NERVOUS THAT HE WASN'T
GOING TO WAIVE HIS HEELS.
I THINK HE'S ALREADY DONE WHAT
HE NEEDS TO DO, REGARDLESS OF
HOW HE WORKS OUT, HE'S NOW GOING
TO BE THE GUY WHO WAS WILLING TO
GO THROUGH WITH THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN TO DIG HIS HEELS ENDS
AND SAY, I'M WILLING TO DO THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
ALSO PROVING THAT HE'S TAKING ON
LANGUAGE AND SAY, THIS IS A
DEMOCRAT SHUTDOWN.
HE IS TAKING ON THE LANGUAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT A SHUTDOWN
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE.
IT'S NOT THERE'S ARMAGEDDON THAT
THE LEFT PAINTS IT TO BE.
SO MANY ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION STILL WORKING.
I WATCHED CHUCK SCHUMER AND HE
SAYS, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
YOUR WALL, AS IF TO    TO THE WL
YOUR WALL, AS IF TO    TO THE WI
YOUR WALL, AS IF TO    TO THE WS
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE WALL IS FOR THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT'S FOR OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
IT'S TO ADDRESS THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT RESOURCES
FOR BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
YOU JUST HAD A LITTLE GIRL DIE
CROSSING IN HORRIFIC CONDITIONS.
THIS IDEA THAT HE'S NOT GIVING
HIM THE MONEY TO SPIKE TRUMP?
YOU'RE NOT SPITING TRUMP.
YOU'RE SPITING AMERICAN CITIZENS
AND SPITING ALL THE POOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEING INCENTIVIZED TO
COME ACROSS THIS BORDER UNDER
THESE HORRIFIC CONDITIONS.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD TAKE A MINUTE
TO REFLECT ON THAT AND I KNOW IT
SOUNDS GOOD TO OPPOSE THE WALL,
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
OPPOSING, WHICH IS ADDRESSING
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
I THINK HE'S DONE ALL THAT HE'S
HAD TO DO.
>> JEDEDIAH, YOU'RE SO LUCKY
BECAUSE SANTA DELIVERED FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU GOT A DEMOCRAT AT
THE TABLE.
I SAY, HEY, JEDEDIAH, I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID MEXICO WILL
PAY FOR THE WALL.
>> HE SHOULD'VE NEVER BEEN ON
RECORD SAYING THAT BECAUSE IT'S
UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU HAVE
PEOPLE OPENING GO FUND ME
ACCOUNTS TO SAY, IF THE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOING TO DO
IT, WE SHOULD DO IT.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
GOVERNMENT IS TO PROTECT ITS
CITIZENS SO THAT INCLUDES BORDER
SECURITY.
>> ONE FINAL QUESTION OF IS FOR
EVERYBODY.
JESSE LAID OUT A POTENTIAL END
GAME, THE WAY A PRESIDENT CAN
GET OUT OF IT, I DID MY BEST,
I'VE TRIED WITH THESE DEMOCRATS.
I WENT TO THE POINT, I THINK
JEDEDIAH PICKED UP ON THIS, WE
ARE GOING TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
RUSH LIMBAUGH, "THE DRUDGE"
REPORT, BREITBART, YOU DID YOUR
BEST WITH THOSE DOGGONE
DEMOCRATS.
>> HE GOES OUT AND DOES AS MUCH
AS HE CAN, YOU LOOK AT MITCH
McCONNELL OR LOOK AT THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS AND SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THEY DIDN'T DELIVER WITH
THE TWO HERE IS HAVE MAJORITIES,
EVEN THEN YOU STILL NEED 60
VOTES.
YOU NEED TO NUKE IT.
YOU NEED NUKE OPTION OR NOTHING.
>> WHEN HE STARTS HAMMERING THE
TABLE --
>> IT DOES WITH ME UP, THOUGH.
WATCHING POLITICIANS DEBATE OVER
IS LIKE WATCHING ME AND DANA GET
SOMETHING FROM A HIGH SHELF.
THERE IS NO EXPERTISE.
THE MISTAKE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS IS NOT INTRODUCING
EXPERTISE IN THIS PROBLEM.
INSTEAD, IT STARTED WITH A
PRICE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO RENOVATE
YOUR HOUSE, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
SAY, I'M GOING TO SPEND THIS.
YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU NEED TO
RENOVATE.
DO I NEED A TABLE HERE.
THEN YOU COME UP WITH A BUDGET.
THIS IS -- I WAS GOING TO SAY
ASS BACKWARDS.
CAN I SAY THAT?
I THINK WHAT WE NEEDED IS
ENGINEERING EXPERTISE, SOME OF
THAT SAYS, OKAY -- MAYBE YOU
HAVE A WALL HERE, DON'T HAVE A
WALL HERE, YOU COME UP WITH IT.
YOU STARTED FROM THE REVERSE.
THAT MIGHT BE A COMPROMISE.
>> HOW ABOUT OUR PUBLIC
RELATIONS EXPERT MRS. PERINO?
>> I DO THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION WAS ABLE TO DO.
IT WAS ACTUALLY QUITE IMPERATIV
IMPERATIVE.
SECRETARY OF DEPARTMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY KIRSTJEN NIELSEN
ANNOUNCED THEY HAVE REACHED THIS
DEAL WITH MEXICO -- BASICALLY
SAID THAT MEXICO IS GOING TO
HOUSE OR HOLD THE ASYLUM-SEEKER
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
IF YOU ARE A MIGRANT, YOU COME
ACROSS, YOU GET PROCESSED, BUT
THEN YOU WAIT IN MEXICO.
THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE LOTS
OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE A
PART OF THE WHOLE CUTLERY SET.
>> YES.
>> THERE IS A SPOON, KNIFE, FOR
FORK.
>> THAT SMALLER KNIFE.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THEY
ARE DOING OUTSIDE OF THE WALL
THAT CAN GIVE THEM COVER WITH
THEIR BASE BUT TO LET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW, THEY
AREN'T WAITING $5 BILLION FOR
STEEL SLOTS FOR A WALL, THAT'S
ACTUALLY IMPRESSIVE.
SHE DESERVES SOME CREDIT FOR
THAT.
IT GOT BURIED BECAUSE OF ALL THE
OTHER BREAKING NEWS.
SPEAK OF THE SUPREME COURT HAD A
RULING, JEDEDIAH, THAT SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION CANNOT PUT A CAP
ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE SEEKING
ASYLUM.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
VOTED WITH THE LIBERALS AGAINST
THE ADMINISTRATION.
>> THAT IS TRUE AS WELL.
I ALSO SAY THE DOLLAR VALUE,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DEBATE
ABOUT THE $5 BILLION.
HE IS NOT JUST PULLING THAT
NUMBER OUT OF THIN AIR, HE IS
TALKING TO BORDER CONTROL
AGENTS, TALKING TO PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER, THEY ARE TELLING HIM
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED.
THIS IS WHAT IS SUFFICIENT.
CHUCK TO
SUMER        , CHUCK SCHUMER DOE
SUMER        , CHUCK SCHUMER DON
SUMER        , CHUCK SCHUMER DOT
DECIDE WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF MONEY, SO IT IS
DONALD TRUMP YOUR HE'S WORKING
WITH PEOPLE ON THE BORDER.
HE'S TRYING TO PROCESS PEOPLE,
GET THEM IN BUSES IN THESE
REMOTE AREAS TO OTHER LOCATIONS,
MAKE SURE THE PROPER MEDICAL
SUPPLIES ARE THERE, CONTAIN
WHAT'S GOING ON.
THAT NUMBER -- THERE'S A REASON
THE $5 BILLION, IN TERMS OF A
MONETARY VALUE, EVEN EXIST.
>> GREG, DOES HE GO TO
MAR-A-LAGO IF THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTS DOWN?
>> WELL, I'LL TALK TO HIM LATER.
I'M GOING TO HITCH A RIDE BACK